venezuela se prepara para el desarrollo
de sus comicios legislativos
pero en los barrios más afectados por la
crisis financiera y social algunos se
debaten entre la resignación y la
impotencia el motivo al domingo de no
hacer algo quiero hacer algo y que seas
una mortal y por supuesto en contra de
todo sinvergüenza poder haber hecho otra
cosa que pero condicionando a la miseria
por un fallo legal que les quitó las
tarjetas electorales los mayores
partidos opositores no podrán participar
en estas elecciones que fueron
convocadas por el gobierno de nicolás
maduro para renovar la asamblea nacional
ante ellos juan guaidó advirtió sobre
fraudes en la jornada
pero si la organización de estados
américanos
la unión europea en pleno la unidad de
todos los factores en venezuela reunida
en sus partidos políticos por unanimidad
han decidido no participar por ser un
fraude no reunir condiciones yo le pido
un favor no había elección
porque a una en la narrativa de una
dictadura violadora de derechos humanos
entre tanto altos mandos del chavismo
como el presidente de la asamblea
constituyente de diosdado cabello han
intensificado la presión entre sus
simpatizantes
el que no bote' no come se le aplica una
cuarentena y
sin comer
así las cosas todo indica que la jornada
del domingo el gobierno socialista
ganaría la mayoría de la asamblea
nacional en medio de la profunda
división que vive la oposición